eh bien le bonjour à tous je suis
vraiment ravi de vous faire cette
présentation tadjiks en visio mais vous
le savez ça devait se passer normalement
en présentiel dans le bel amphithéâtre
de la ftp est en fait j'avais prévu une
super punch line pour captiver votre
attention
du coup j'ai besoin d'un peu de votre
aide sur ce coup là je vais vous
demander de fermer les yeux de vous
imaginez bien confortablement installé
dans l'ubaye l'amphi cas de le ftp
tout est sombre tout est calme les
lumières sont rivés sur scène et là
j'arrive et je vous dis il y à ce que
l'on vous donne à la naissance est ce
que vous en faites
alors j'ai captiver votre attention là
non bon j'avoue c'est un peu cliché dit
comme ça mais je vous assure que c'est
vrai on a tous en nous des traits de
caractère plus ou moins exacerbée selon
notre parcours notre génétique et les
expériences que l'on dit est aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous montrez que vous pouvez
aller au-delà de ce que vous croyez en
créant coup et transformez vos
faiblesses de force ce qui a longtemps
été ma plus grande faiblesse c'est mon
hypersensibilité est ce que ça vous est
déjà arrivé de fondre en larmes quand on
vous demande juste si ça va ou de partir
hurlé après une réunion qui se serait
mal passé vous avez de la chance je peux
pas vous voir à travers l'écran mais si
j'en crois les statistiques 20% des
personnes d'entre vous sont comme moi
alors tous les êtres humains sont dotés
de sensibilité c'est à dire être apte à
éprouver des sensations des perceptions
des sentiments d'humanité envers autrui
et l'hypersensibilité c'est tout
simplement une sensibilité plus intense
plus accrue que la moyenne
c'est un trait de caractère inné et qui
se manifeste de différentes manières
chez les individus selon l'environnement
dans lequel ils évoluent donc voilà rien
de grave
mais je suis hypersensible et ça a
longtemps été un handicap pour moi un
handicap invisible pour les autres mais
aujourd'hui et pas vraiment par choix
j'ai réussi à faire de cette faiblesse
une force
alors pour vous comprenez un peu mieux
comment j'ai fait ça je vais vous
raconter mon histoire ayant évolué dans
un contexte d'exigences de soi très
jeune j'ai été contrainte d'étouffer mon
hypersensibilité donc enfants je donner
l'apparence d'une fille très forte très
résistante
je ne pleurais jamais met en opposition
à cela et la partie immergée de
l'iceberg
c'était qu'à la moindre contrariété je
m'effondrais de manière démesurée
par exemple si je n'avais pas le droit
de manger un bonbon j'allais partir en
criant hurlant en pleurant dans ma
chambre pour vous montrer un peu la
démesure puis en grandissant cette
carapace que je m'étais forget se
fissurer peu à peu
l'iceberg remonter à la surface donc la
pression les critiques les remarques ou
toute situation inhabituelle mais minime
m'affecter énormément je ne parvenais
pas à gérer mes émotions je vous rendez
compte et j'en avais tellement c'était
insupportable
en fait c'était devenu presque
quotidiens de pleurer pour un passage au
tableau raté une mauvaise note ou une
simple remarque sur la manière de couper
du gâteau alors ça j'en ai entendu des
eaux savard et de pleurer pour un ou des
mais qu'est ce que tu peux être
susceptibles en fait je n'arrivais pas à
exprimer mes émotions et mes seule
possibilité était de me renfermer sur
moi de fondre en larmes ou d' exploser
de rage et de frapper de toutes mes
forces contre un mur on va ça je vous le
déconseille parce que ça fait très mal
je repense par exemple pendant les
projets de groupe à l'école avec je me
sentais mise à l'écart que plutôt que de
m'imposer je me renfermais davantage sur
moi et j'attendais la fin pour aller
pleurer dans les toilettes et encore
quand j'attendais quand j'arrivais
jusqu'à la fin c'était un miracle
vous voyez c'est mon
on a le sentiment de ne pas être normal
d'être un alien un peu c'était
exactement ce que je ressentais dans ces
moments là mais personne ne le voyait
c'était invisible aux yeux de tous les
seules personnes qui me comprenait
étaient mes proches c'étaient les seuls
à me connaître réellement et grâce à qui
je ne perdais papiers ayant toujours été
très bien entouré j'ai vraiment compris
la dimension de mon hypersensibilité
quand j'ai perdu tous ses piliers de mon
confort de vie cette année là j'avais 16
ans je venais d'avoir mon bac cette
année là mes parents sont séparés
mon père est parti vivre à paris ma mère
restée à montpellier et moi j'ai quitté
la maison pour entrer en prépa j'ai
perdu tous mes repères mais ça ne
suffisait pas cette année là je suis
aussi tombé dans l'anorexie et j'ai dû
me rendre compte que je faisais fausse
route en faisant une prépa pour être
vétérinaire
oui je voulais être vétérinaire avant de
perdre le stp
si vous cherchez le rapport je vous
rassure moi je le cherche encore
enfin voilà cette année là le puzzle de
ma vie est tombé par terre et je me suis
retrouvé sans plus aucun chemin tracé
déboussolés alors pour me reconstruire
j'ai été obligé finalement de m'accepter
tels que j'étais et d'accepter cette
sensibilité que j'avais en moi et
finalement je pense que comme toute
faiblesse pour la surpasser il faut
d'abord en prendre conscience
dans son ensemble et moi c'est vraiment
ce qui m'a aidé j'étais perdue à cause
de cette hypersensibilité que j'avais au
monde extérieur alors je m'en suis servi
pour la retourner sur moi pour me sondés
pour me trouver pour trouver ma voie mon
chemin a continué deux ans plus tard
lorsque j'étais déjà entré à la ftp
quand je suis parti en ethiopie c'était
pour une mission humanitaire de cinq
semaines à 15 heures de marche de la
moindre biais une nouvelle fois je
vivais une rupture totale avec tous mes
repères partir seul
avec des gens que je ne connaissais pas
loin de tout sans connexion ni réseau
pour être en relation avec mes proches
et pour pratiquer une activité physique
qui me terrorisait la randonnée en haute
montagne
je me suis retrouvé seul face à toutes
ces émotions qui me submerger et que je
ne savais pas gérer les gens qui étaient
avec moi ne comprenais pas mais
renfermement sur moi mes peurs
irrationnelles mes crises de panique ou
mes crises de rage et étant loin de mes
proches j'ai été obligé d'apprendre à
les exprimer ses émotions à mettre des
mots dessus et surtout à me montrer tels
que j'étais à oser être qui je suis
vraiment et en faisant ça j'ai réussi
petit à petit à m'ouvrir aux autres
essais en m'ouvrant à eux qu'il
s'ouvrait à - retour finalement et là
j'ai compris j'ai pris conscience de
l'empathie extrême que j'avais qui s'est
révélé et à ce moment là j'ai réalisé
que cette hypersensibilité même si
c'était une immense faiblesse c'était
aussi une très grande force parce qu'en
fait comme entre 2 et contre tout
extrême finalement la limite entre le
positif et le négatif est très faible et
il suffit d'un petit levier pour révéler
tout le positif invisible alors
évidemment ce levier sera plus ou moins
brutale selon les tempéraments les
parcours de chacun mais personne n'est
voué à rester bloqué dans ce qu'ils
croient figé en lui d'ailleurs nous
sommes bien des êtres vivants donc apte
à évoluer pour atteindre cet équilibre
aujourd'hui je pense que je les attends
enfin en bonne voie pour atteindre cet
équilibre en tout cas au moins j'ai
compris que je ne suis pas mélodies
hypersensible mais juste mélodies et que
l'hyper sensibilité fait partie de moi
sans définir mal
aujourd'hui j'arrive à trouver des
exutoires à ces supers sensations autre
que donner des coups de poing dans un
mur j'entends aujourd'hui j'écris des
poèmes je réalise des films et je fais
beaucoup de sport m'a un peu de
randonnée et aujourd'hui j'arrive à me
servir de ce surplus de sensations pour
me connecter aux autres pour me mettre à
leur place les comprendre les aider pour
avoir une forte conscience de mon
environnement et surtout pour me
connecter aux autres parlé avec mon
coeur en nous connectant aussi à moi
même et en parlant de ça ça me rappelle
une anecdote
c'était pendant un entretien dans gauche
le recruteur me disait enfin le
recruteur m'a dit mais vous êtes tout le
temps timide comme ça alors moi qui
faisait des efforts surhumains pour
paraître à l'aise je tombais des nues
quelques mois auparavant j'aurais fondu
en larmes
mais là je me suis recentré sur moi je
me suis dit mélodies tu ne pleures pas
sinon c'est fini pour toi alors j'ai
déglutit un bon coup j'ai imaginé le
recruteur sur les toilettes ça ça va
être vraiment un protêt dramatiser une
situation et je lui ai simplement dit
que j'étais un peu stressé mais quand on
normal j'étais pas du tout comme ça
écoutez ça a dû marcher puisque j'avais
été prise pour le poste et maintenant
que je suis dans le monde du travail
je me rends compte de la toux qui cette
hypersensibilité pour amener un peu
d'humanité dans le leadership dans le
management d'une équipe
dans notre société où les émotions sont
trop souvent mise en arrière-plan
alors qu'elles font complètement partie
de notre quotidien dans la vie de tous
les jours au travail
maintenant j'arrive grâce à cette
hypersensibilité à lire entre les lignes
à comprendre ce qu'on ne le dit pas et à
le mettre en place très rapidement
finalement parce que j'utilise et je
perçois les émotions autant que les mous
et ça d'ailleurs ça me fait penser à une
anecdote encore
c'était pendant une réunion on était
quatre dans la salle de réunion et
chacun défendu son point de vue sans
réellement écouté les autres
voyez ce genre de situation chacun a ses
bornes et sans écouter les autres et moi
je ne disais rien j'ai observé la
situation j'étais assez silencieuse
j'analyse les comportements les les
opinions de chacun et à un moment je me
suis décidé à prendre la parole et en
une phrase j'ai mis tout le monde
d'accord
et là j'ai compris que même si c'était
une super faiblesse une hypersensibilité
était aussi un super pouvoir
alors je sais vous allez dire je suis
encore jeune mais je pense qu'il n'y a
pas d'âge pour prendre conscience de qui
on est vraiment de toutes les ressources
qu'on en de ces différences qui font
notre unicité
vous êtes les seuls à savoir ce qui est
réellement vous est ce dont vous êtes
réellement capable car c'est invisible
pour les autres il ne tient qu'à vous de
transformer vos faiblesses en forces une
hypersensibilité été ma plus grande
faiblesse
mais c'est aujourd'hui ma plus grande
force alors ce n'est qu'un exemple très
personnelle mais je suis certaine que
chacun d'entre vous peut trouver son
hypersensibilité à lui son talon
d'achille
elle s'appellera simplement différemment
timidité complexe perfectionnisme le
challenge est d'autant plus grand
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une faiblesse mais
oser vous accepter ça vaut tellement le
coup je laisse à chacun d'entre vous
donner un nom à son hypersensibilité et
en faire son ami merci
[Applaudissements]
le problème avec lui